hey everybody and welcome to a very
snoochy boochie wild ride with stevo we
got jason mears who by the way so many
of you people have requested we were
thrilled to book him who is he well he's
the star of a little-known franchise
called jay and silent bob starred in
huge movies like clerks alongside matt
damon ben affleck oh come on this guy's
epic plus he and i both have checkered
pasts riddled with addiction and we're
both doing really well for ourselves
today so this one is inspiring it's a
lot of fun it's very snoochy booty so
let's get into it
let's have your bite your mic just down
a bit so that it's not blocking you from
the kitchen like this oh okay
like just push the arm down
okay yeah i mean yeah there you go dude
hey this is the gator and the lunatic i
should i thought you stream right
how am i twitch now okay because i've
been streaming
people
how many people come on and they're like
dude you sound like stevo
and i'm like all right
we're keeping that in
ladies and gentlemen
jason muse
hello hello um dude thanks for having me
this is awesome um
yeah would you would you believe it that
like you're the most requested guest on
the comment section
you're highly highly requested really
yeah you and theo vaughn are the most
requested well i didn't know that yeah
steve will do it had been i think first
place
and uh and he was a banger and who was
it sorry this is steve will do it is uh
he's one of the elk boys it's sort of uh
and then
he's a youtuber he's a youtuber
okay
how old are you 47. me too dude right
now man yeah how about that um we were
in a movie together you and me
i bet you don't even know that yes i
think it was uh it was the college uh
national orlando yeah tv the movie i
know but it stinks because we didn't
cross right right right i mean whatever
dude you were hilarious in that movie
dude you were
a gay prison inmate thank you yeah it
was fun again it's funny how many um
there's so many there's so many indie
movies i've done over the years and and
again for the most i remember most of
them because i always have a blast but
um it's funny because i'll forget though
overall how many and then so every once
in a while i'll go on imdb to just check
look at something i'll be like oh my
gosh i forgot i did this yeah i got this
yeah so
i go on and i'm like [ __ ] is that all
i did more are you updated or
automatically no i think it's autumn i
think other people do it like they just
yeah because and but all just like just
like um
wikipedia it's funny i i know other
people do it it's like hey man i heard
you used to write for this band i'm like
i wish like i net and like we heard you
play bass i'm like no and i didn't do
any of those fun cool things but so a
lot of it's inaccurate but i think it's
because people will hear something and
add it and same with imdb i believe but
i could be wrong about imdb because i
know that yeah they've gotten sort of
let's be a bot because i have a producer
credit on your guilty as charge and i
never even yeah well i gave you a
producer credit yeah but did you who
puts it on imdb
you would think that yeah i mean think
the paperwork it's pretty
like you would think that even though he
put you on it and you're wondering who
did like i think whoever produced that
movie has to put you on and there's so
much involved to it i'm learning more
and more because
my wife produces
uh has produced kevin's last three
movies uh wow yoga hosers jay and son
bob reboot and and uh clerks three so uh
again i hear on the phone and i hear
she's doing like there's so much
involved with everything and and uh i
had no idea even doing this way longer
than her i've been doing it you know 25
years but i had no idea until being in
the same room with their like even for
us to do clerks 3 it took so long
because it was like
when someone owns a movie if they sell
it off they sell it off like in pieces
and it's like they own the rights to
this but this person owns the rights to
that and there was all this stuff that i
had no idea that's my point so
see your wife is prolific
she's my
it's awesome you know i met she's uh 13
years younger than i am
my fiancee is 13 years younger than me
you guys have the same voice same live
same everything exactly exactly and we
uh
i met her when she was going to college
still and she wanted to be a lawyer when
she got done uh she's like i'm gonna
take a break and it just happened that
kevin was asking her kevin and i were
doing things together and kevin's
assistant had left so he was like hey
man do you think you can help me with
this and asked her to help out with a
few things and she did it so well he's
like can you help me with these things
and then all of a sudden we started way
back we did something called uh
the the uh smart we did an internet
radio uh
i'm familiar with that yeah way back we
we were doing morning radio on the
internet
and he asked her to help out with it and
anyway she just sort of fell into is my
point but yeah she's uh it's been great
because
just especially like when we just shot
clerks we were in jersey for three
months and normally you know you'd have
to leave your wife or fiance whatever
but i was able to you know the wife came
with me with our six-year-old because
she was working and i was working and
the kid
was in the movie she got to do a cameo
now so she's done two cameos so so it's
cool it's a literally a family affair
because kevin and i are so close
um you know we've been friends 30 years
we have our comic book store in new
jersey we've owned for 25 years almost
um
you know so him and he his family is my
family and they've been so it's pretty
awesome it's been it's been pretty
amazing so i'm still i'm still uh
soaking in that i'm one of your top
comments crazy yes yeah requested guest
that is so i hope i do justice i don't
know what you guys want to see maybe a
little
you know um
he said that his wife had a cameo in the
movie and this is probably like it's
probably inappropriate for me to say for
a bunch of reasons but but your wife is
unbelievably beautiful well thank you
thank you thank god the kid got to be in
the movies so it's cool but thank you
so i mean yeah and uh i can't help but
when you say you know you've been
you know doing stuff with with kevin for
for so long
and uh you know i remember you and i
linking up on twitter we were going to
meet up we were going to do some stuff
like uh
and um
it i i don't know
what what was going on at that time but
clearly there was some some periods in
your relationship with kevin where he
had to just back off he's like yeah yeah
like you're
you're not okay right now yeah like what
what uh
that's good just gotta be tough man
did did him
having to
sort of you know put a boundary in place
and back off and say you need to get
well
like did was there uh like a financial
consequence to that
got to give it to jason for being very
cool about me putting him in
uncomfortable positions and i gotta tell
you i'm about to put myself in a very
comfortable position
because dude my bluetooth tablets are so
much fun and get this i somehow didn't
even notice that right here on the
package it says chew one to two tablets
by mouth
30 to 45 minutes before sexual activity
as needed and all this time i had only
been taking one
so
man
doubling up on my bluetooth tablets has
proven to be
the most fun and i'm gonna do it right
now because i'm telling you when lux
gets home she's gonna get it so
if you haven't tried this yet let me
tell you you're missing out on a lot of
fun
and how can you try it absolutely for
free with your own
month supply that all you have to pay is
five bucks for shipping to get oh man
you go to bluechew.com and you use the
promo code stevo
like it's so easy you don't even have to
go to the doctor's office for some
awkward in-person visit no no
you go to bluetooth.com and you consult
with one of their medical providers
it's so fast and simple and then boom
you're set you get an entire month's
supply
completely for free if you use the promo
code stevo
at bluechew.com and
one more time i'm telling you it is so
much fun you're out of your mind if you
don't try it
so go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code stevo and get ready to have a whole
lot of fun
now let's talk about jay and silent bob
um yeah i mean well i think
you know it made sense to me always
i mean there was always he never
for him and i it's like so yeah there
was for one it was like hey i need you
to sort of get better or you can't be
around the house
and you can't do the next movie like i
was supposed to be in jersey girl but i
couldn't be in it but it wasn't so much
like kevin was like
i'm not putting you in a hundred percent
because uh you're you're getting messed
up and you're in a bad place it was more
like hey you have a warrant out for your
arrest and we're filming we're filming
in in philadelphia or pittsburgh
wherever they filmed it and you could
get arrested and then it'll like well to
shut the movie down you know i mean
right right um you will lose days so
there was like that so so that happened
a few times but not not that i didn't
get in the movie because in the past he
would always try to help me like hey if
this is you don't want to miss out on
this opportunity then you need to either
go into rehab or you're going to come
stay with me and you're going to get off
and you're going to stick by my side
like the right before jan saw bob
strikes back
i i went and stayed with him in his
guest house and i literally couldn't
leave his house or leave the guest house
unless i was with him
and if he was going somewhere else i had
to go with him he wouldn't leave me
alone but it was a good it was a sweet
thing he's boxing yeah because he's like
oh dude yeah we he got
he got to see it up closer i remember it
was during christmas
and i had to go christmas shopping with
them and we were in the mall and you
know you just you're detoxing from
opiates you feel like you're carrying a
bag of bricks and you're just like your
nose is running and i remember just
sitting down on every bench throughout
the mall while he was in there looking
for presents and i'm like er like an
hour seemed like at six hours you know
and i remember just be like i wanna go
and he'd like dude no you gotta wait
another like we're gonna get through
this and i didn't it was it was horrible
but in the end it was worth it because
then i got to do reboot and i mean
strikes back and it was great but uh you
know for me
it also like i never
resented him or was upset with him about
it because it the biggest thing was his
kid at the time all these times his
kid's now 20 uh 20 damn i give him about
old she is not 23. but at the time she
was like you know 10
12 uh you know eight years old i've ever
all the different years she was but it
was always like hey i don't want she's
getting older now she sees you she looks
up to your uncle jay
and if you come to the house we used to
be able to tell her oh he's not feeling
good he's got a cold he's sick he's not
but she she's gonna get it now and i
don't want her to see like that and i
didn't want her to see me like that so
you know i would stay away and try to
get better but for the most part he
always was involved with trying to help
either he stuck me in rehab drove me
there paid for it or you know again that
time uh you know i didn't go i went to a
detox but then after i got out i got out
in like a week and then i stayed at his
house i was still withdrawing because it
was off of uh oxies which you know isn't
a week it's like a month um getting off
of that feeling physically uh okay with
that but uh yeah you know it's it's been
he's always stuck by even when he put
boundaries up it's not like he ever just
cut me off again we got to a point one
point where he he got close but it more
was like hey you're in really really bad
shape the kid's old enough to like
see you
um and i just need you to make a
decision like go get go get better or i
just can't have you around like it
breaks my heart and he would like cry
and stuff you know it was never like a
mean thing like for sure a scumbag get
out of here it was like you're breaking
my heart and he would cry and you know i
don't want you around the kid and and
yeah there's a there was a time i
remember i went to his house it was
thanksgiving and i always used to have
thanksgiving with him and i remember him
me and him sitting out in front of his
house um and him crying and being like i
want to let you in but the whole
family's here and i had like a tank top
on and i had track marks and you know
he's like i can't have you see him like
that is and he's like i'm like i can't
come in for a plate of thanksgiving
dinner and he's like you can't he's like
here i'm gonna bring you some food but i
don't want the kid to see you that way
and it made sense to me but it was like
that was that was the first time i
actually got sober for like a while i
had stayed sober for like four years
um and then i got kidney stones and they
gave me demerol i was like i don't want
anything i don't want anything i'm sober
i'm in the program and they were like
yeah but if you want to pass the kidney
stone you got to take it and they gave
me that shot man and it was like brought
back that that beast and i was like oh i
forgot about this this is great you know
i mean the next thing you know it was
like oh i could handle it and they gave
me uh pills to go home with and you know
i was counting every four hours and
anyway so then i relapsed for two years
and now i have uh 11 years wow dude brad
man was the rock bottom for you nodding
off and hitting the cop car
i read that in an article did you pass
out at a
stoplight and run into a cop you didn't
do that i didn't do that thank goodness
i honestly i lucked out man i i i never
i got arrested once i don't say i looked
out i got arrested once
um in jersey 1999 i i was driving with a
deployed air bag
apparently you can't do that so i
crashed and we crashed into a regular
car
and we exchanged information and then we
went and copped our dope and then on the
way home this girl i was dating on the
way home we had the car was all smashed
and the airbag we just pushed back in so
it was it wasn't like full but it was
like it was hanging out like it was
there so we're like driving back and we
got pulled over then for that and i had
i had a couple bags on me and i'm like i
should eat him i should eat a man while
i get rid of it and i'll be fine but i'm
like there's no way they're gonna search
me there's no way they're gonna search
me just for no reason and they search me
i got arrested and i got uh
ror and then i got uh probation and
stuff luckily but that was the only time
in all the many oh all the years of
getting uh
using and stuff like there was times i
lucked out where like cops like stopped
and was like hey come here and i like
ran and got away but i had like bags on
me and syringes and crack pipes
like i'm telling you this one
is fast when you got all that [ __ ] on
you
i'm gonna tell you this is like
i tell this story because it's it
i really do think about it all the time
because i had a warrant in new jersey
um and
and i was in la and i had all this stuff
on me and there was this there was like
a office building an empty lot and
another office building and there was a
fence and a fence to like this back
street and it was la brea and i was
walking and the cop pulls over and he's
like hello hey hey
and i turn around i see him and i go
what am i going to do so i hop the fence
and i start to run to the other side of
the road and all that cop had to do is
stand at that fence and let his partner
drive to the other side and cut me off
but the guy jumped in the car and went
with them and i heard him get in the car
and screech off so because they were
going to the other side so i turned
around went back the way i came so my
point is is that one decision that
caught me like if the cops stayed there
i would have been arrested and i and it
would have been like my third second
time getting arrested from the 99 and
i'm just saying that would have
literally changed my life and and uh
luckily the cop decided to get back in
the car and drive around and i got away
that time but i don't know there was a
few times i got lucky like that man and
and uh yeah i don't know i mean luckily
i
all the trouble i i had i had kevin's
support and and i know that was a big
made a big difference in in the outcome
of of everything because
i always had looked forward to like i'd
get sober because i wanted to do the
next movie and i was like you can't do
right yeah you can't do propagation yeah
your motivation can't be
like financial or for
power property and prestige we call it
yeah yeah dude um and i'll tell you i'm
looking at you we're the same age i'm
just like green with jealousy over how
much younger you look than i do i really
look at the mirror my shit's falling
apart dude like i'm posting videos on my
instagram story and i'm like god damn
you know if i was a fan of steve i'd be
like he looks like crap
no no you know you don't look that bad
no no
i mean you look great
that's the only point yeah you look so i
think you look like this though
thanks man
thanks dear i would say i would i would
think this is like maybe five years ago
and you look about five years older all
right
um so wait if you don't mind who who is
the judge
scott uh here
yeah
scott randolph our mutual buddy dk yes
but
so do you produce the the what we're
doing or is he one of your best friends
or something
technically i would say is the producer
more right yeah i think so paul edits it
all together he's the producer editor
predator he's more of a wow dude he's
more of a
co-host okay but
scott and i work in in almost every area
of my business selling merchandise and
stuff yeah very nice okay touring
scott's my tour manager right now and uh
in in producing uh digital content you
know both of these guys are producers in
their own right you know then steve
needs to find something like a pitching
machine i'll go find that oh and i like
that that's my latest request it's a
pitching machine so are you still doing
like what's uh are you still doing some
crazy things
that's absolutely right i'm gonna tell
you the whole idea because i love liquid
death and i'm gonna use a pitching
machine to fire a can of it right at my
face and why do i love liquid death well
it's pure mountain spring water from the
alps and it comes in an infinitely
recyclable can which looks like a beer
can just a lot of fun and they are
trying to bring death to plastic because
plastic sucks man and liquid death rules
you know i'm also very much healthier
because i've been drinking so much more
water since i fell in love with liquid
death
and if you're drinking a lot of soda no
bueno man switch to this sparkling
liquid death and uh you're gonna be a
lot healthier too
join this company and saving the world
man death to plastic big ups to the
liquid death and you know what for the
listeners of the wild ride podcast if
you go to liquiddeth.com
stevo you get free shipping on all your
orders of merch and water and do you
know how heavy water is to ship you're
going to get it shipped for free
unbelievable deal from unbelievably cool
people who are talking about saving the
world so dudes
go to liquiddeth.com
stevo and check out how dope their merch
is get free shipping on water and merch
and be a healthier person okay
dude liquid death man let's talk about
firing it on my face
i i i'm in love with this company called
liquid death right they're they're
hilarious
it's canned water they have sparkles
oh by the way can i get one i'd [ __ ]
need one dude are they they can't beat
them in the fridge
yeah in any case one of these cans okay
it's a 16 i'm selling it back but i just
i see that it's the same circumference
size roughly as a baseball okay so i
feel like with the pitching machine with
the two wheels that if you were to
to find to stick it in there then it
would shoot the camera i think i could i
think i could shoot a can of water 100
[ __ ] miles an hour out of a pitching
machine and if i'm
thank you and if i'm wearing a catcher's
uh mask right with like you know and i
got my head up against like something
like a hundred miles an hour like can
right into my face with the catcher's
mask on
i think is doable i like it i like it i
would definitely protect your neck
because i think if it if it missed the
mix right right right right
my concern is also the metal
shrapnel that will continue going
that that that into your face
maybe it's not gonna
kill you but
but if there's like a grid here i don't
know well they have the visors catch
during the sunny games
there you go protecting the sun
and i wonder if it all works it'll be
fun trying to see it yesterday right and
um it's it's and what i think is
particularly funny we found uh on
craigslist i think it is
like a guy selling one it's like 800
bucks for this pitching machine and i'm
ready to buy it but i want to make sure
it works so we'll show up in person and
say hey before we commit to this you
know i need to stick
but you can only do it if you got to put
a ball in it because again what are you
saying you're only going to buy it if
the can goes through but he's like
because in his eyes he's going to be
like hey it works if a ball you put a
ball in it'll work
i don't know if the candle works exactly
so
the cans gotta work i'm not buying it i
think you can create it i think you can
crank it like this and it goes from like
a softball
to a ball it's true that makes sense it
does yeah because yeah because you would
want think it would yeah it changed but
the um the like
you know
it grabs the ball the texture of the
outside of the ball and shoots it this
might be kind of slippy you know it
doesn't work because they do you don't
want condensation
yeah but footballs are grippy they're
leather
this is
metal so do you know these cats it's
funny i do i do we just had these on
clerks three and they were handing them
out and i'm like bro i don't drink beer
man
i'm like oh wait it's water and it's
called the tall boy they're awesome
they're awesome they really are there it
took me a while to wrap my head around
it as a sober guy when they first
started it's like i was like oh man like
but
so i i'm gonna say here if this works i
feel like if you do attempt this
maybe i can be part of it and i could be
the one throwing the can in there hey
man can i do it i i love it yeah
we're gonna do this here on myself on
your show dude i love it asking you
shall we
then i'd feel bad though like if
something bad did happen it like hit
your shoulders shoulder blades shattered
off
now wait wait wait what did i do
i'm generally like as much of a reckless
[ __ ] as i can be like pretty thought
through when it comes to stuff like i
like it i like it again i'm down i'm
throwing it out there i'm down it fell
dead that's possible i love it man
you live nearby huh yeah yeah it took me
seven minutes to get here a little bit
across right the hollywood bowl i live
right behind it on the street right
behind that so right where dk lives i
don't know if you've been in the decay
is that he so he lives you know all
these mentions of dk i'd like to just
say dk is our guy
who uh who does our podcast for us and
by does our podcast he places all of the
sponsorship all the ads he sells the ads
and uh man i had the idea to get into
podcasting long before i did it and and
i was looking at like oh they've got
podcast networks they've got like oh
there's so many different options yeah
and god am i glad that we went with dk
then we kept it independent
and he just sells the spots
no he's great he's a great dude he's the
greatest really good he is i met him
yeah we've known each other now since uh
2001. so oh wow um yes i've known him
for a bit and he's been he's another
dude who's been super supportive in that
sure like if i ever need to chat with
anyone i i could always call him and
he's uh yeah he's a good dude to talk to
so um it's it's it's been cool it's been
again things are
things they're called the podcast and we
did you know we've we've been digging it
too it's funny because i think to you
because you've been doing a lot of the
comedy clubs and stuff right
yeah i've been on the comedy club
circuit for 11 years and i've just now
have uh made the leap into theaters oh
very nice yeah i don't i don't know that
we're real i mean i'll continue to book
comedy clubs here and there where it
makes sense but
but yeah the touring's going great yeah
it's it's going to i got i got him to
stand up you know pretty long time ago
and i just stuck with it and over the
course of the time that i did it it
evolved and it turned into like my
stories are about videos that i shot and
so it's like
you know i'm doing my stand-up routine
but then like you know after the bit
then you get to see the the thing that i
that i just told you about because it's
multimedia with the big screen yeah
because i know it come i just started
doing my own solo comedy
venues and i've seen a few where either
i'm leaving and you're coming or
you know vice versa um so it's funny
because we cross paths i always feel
like it's ut i always see like it's you
and then i'm like you just left are you
just you're coming after me or tj miller
um and jamie kennedy i always feel like
right so does that mean you have the
guys have the same agents because like i
always feel like that would be the case
it's the same circuit probably the same
agent but i feel like i don't know i
don't know if it's just maybe we all
sort the tour at the same time you know
we hit the same venues maybe because
i don't know i don't know but it's funny
because i i do feel like i see that we
just happen to be crossing paths a lot
like i just did one in in um
uh
san francisco not san francisco san jose
san jose thank you yeah okay because tj
miller was just there too
that's a that's a great [ __ ] place it
is the san jose improv like with like
what was it was it 450 seats five 500
yeah and it's sort of like that that the
theater style yeah yeah super cool you
know what's crazy about being on the
comedy circuit is that we all do it's
like we're all chasing each other around
like like uh
on some kind of a train
and uh and so everywhere we go
we know that the people
that we're working with
have been working with everybody else
coming through so you can't help but end
up in conversations where it's like okay
who who's the worst you know like what's
the writer who's the biggest nightmare
like he's like
writers yeah yeah mine's easy mine's red
bull that's all i asked for all right
yeah we've got a pot of coffee and uh
and
soda water
so nice we used to have a
salmon fillet for wendy but we don't
even give her raw salmon
does not watch the anymore
she's in the show she's she's a part of
the show nice
yes but yeah it's great man and uh
we've never uh your name's never come up
uh in a bad conversation i've never
heard a bad thing about you good good of
course i understood that you've had your
struggles yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
never like
luckily never anything where you're like
oh man last week we had that muse kid
bro right he was complaining about this
and that i even think that like it
in your addiction not that i knew you
and your addiction but i get the sense
that in your addiction that you were
just a perfectly sweet lovable guy he
was just really sick yeah yeah yeah i
feel like i was the same except for
you know the uh
being desperate i feel like you know the
bummer was for me it was like waking up
and my you know that thought of just
what am i gonna do today how am i
getting money right how am i gonna score
even if i have a lot of money do it
right now do i do i know anybody or do i
want to drive down to a bad area and
risk it and that was you know that was
the for me the struggle and then so
again but yeah i don't feel like i ever
luckily
things always seem to work out to where
i never did anything
too foolish like stealing or robbing or
anything crazy
luckily um you know it always sort of
somehow worked out
um
again but i mean like maybe because
again sometimes people would be like bro
we want you to get help uh but i don't
want you to do something stupid so
there's 40 bucks you know or whatever
that's so funny it reminds me of time i
had a drug dealer
meet up with me right and and he looked
at me and he was trying to get an eight
ball of cocaine and he looked at me and
he's like dude i can't i can't i can't
give this to you unless you [ __ ] eat
something dude and the drug dealer like
drove me
to a place and and and like eat
something like he drove me to a [ __ ]
frozen yogurt shop and and made me eat a
thing of frozen yogurt and then he gave
me the eight balls again
because i have a few more bites there
come on now yeah yeah
finish your greens finish your greens
now
running from cops
um god this was back in 1994 i was i was
following the grateful dead around and i
was i'd show up at the show with like
five bucks and i would buy like three
hits fasted and then sell each of them
for five bucks now i had 15 bucks and i
would like buy something else it was
just this like low-grade drug hustle but
there was one point at uh i want to say
like meadowland stadium in new jersey
towards the end of the tour and i had a
bunch of acid on me
and uh and i was doing a drug deal and i
[ __ ] handed this guy
some acid and he gave me some money
and then i turned my head and there's
two [ __ ] cops just watch that happen
they're like [ __ ] hey and i swear
i've never ran so [ __ ] fast
in my life i tried fully [ __ ] through
the parking lot these cops gave chase
and i'm through the parking lot i'm
[ __ ] around and and here's the
crazier said thank god i got away were
you thinking because i i had i did at
that point acid wouldn't do [ __ ] to me
because you know you take acid every day
it just stops working
like um
yeah lingers too long yeah it's like i
just want to start over but it's it's
also like acid as far as like the laws
go it falls into like a really [ __ ]
yeah you're [ __ ] you're selling acid
like you're going to prison for a long
time you know like that was the thing
about the grateful dead tour and with
all the people following it is that the
grateful dead tour left just in its wake
just all kinds of people in prison for
decades
for selling acid so like you know like
you said if if that cop didn't get into
that car it would have changed your life
like i mean [ __ ] dude like
if i hadn't have been so nimble and so
fast
i would have really had a [ __ ]
problem i would have been in prison for
a [ __ ] long time yeah do you guys uh
as celebrities do you guys have special
drug dealers that like only deal with
celebrities or is it just kind of like
you have to be cautious of that when
you're buying drugs after like a movie
yeah me personally i never
i don't feel like i ever got lucky to
where i found like something where you i
get what you're saying where you get
like a dude delivering that like we'll
specialize and be quiet i feel like i
again when i especially here in l.a like
you go to skid row and [ __ ] yeah like
straight up to down like i had a guy
that i could call but he didn't even
know who i was i remember at one point
being really really like i had no money
and i was really dope sick and i
remember bringing like a poster of one
of my movies signed and like
and like a few like a few like items
that i had and and like i had like a
stereo surround sound
and i brought it all to and i'm like
come on man i have no money i'm sorry i
said come on man come on and i'm like
look at this poster man this is at least
40 bucks right here so he's like i don't
care like he didn't want anything i
brought him but the stereo surround
sound but he still was annoyed about
that so that was my one guy for years
that i dealt with um but yeah i never
had
that like you know
and then coke would for me coke was
always if you go out people would offer
me coke no one ever offered me heroin or
opiates it was a taboo like no one
ever offered that i had to like find
someone and like maybe someone sold a
couple pills or i'd go get heroin would
be downtown and it was the same guy for
a long time
um but yeah not me and not me i don't
know about it the way scott asked that
question i think he was
framing it a little bit more like
uh
you know people who aren't gonna say hey
i sold drugs to jason muse you know but
i think that when you're in the space of
drug dealing like i think that
a little bit of uh discretion kind of
comes along with the turf anyway yeah
you're not putting that on your linkedin
you know like but dude it's crazy to me
to imagine like i think that's kind of
my biggest fear in the [ __ ] whole
world is to be like famous and broke to
be like recognizable and and and like
not have money and like and have a drug
habit like [ __ ] dude that no it was yeah
it's it was uh i mean again for me again
i don't
again i feel like i'm at to i don't feel
like i'm uh up there up there but it it
would for me yes it would be like it's
things that
to have to at one point would have money
and then i wouldn't have money like i'd
make a movie and let's say i had a whole
bunch of money and then by the time i
started buying drugs especially the this
one the one round like i remember i was
because i didn't want to in my head i
thought if i don't get heroin
i'm going to be all right if i'm only
doing vicodin vicodin sort of tame you
know it's not even oxycontin it's it's
vicodin but because i had a habit i was
no lie doing minimum 20 like right
oh so i would taste it through my liver
sometimes
up to 60 a day but that would add up man
that's like even 20 20 is at least 100
bucks so minimum i was spending 100 to
200 bucks a day some days i'd spend 400
bucks a day so you got to think you know
that's what let's say that's 700 bucks a
week
times four is what a month i mean and
that's minimum you know so for like
three months i spent like you know 20
grand on bikini so so then i'll send you
like oh my gosh i almost have like no
money left over because i'm like not
spending it wise and anyway so i agree
and it's such a weird thing where people
are like hey you want to come out like
it's it's it's yeah but i could see that
especially for me now even more so
because i feel like i have a family and
all that stuff and and i can't even
imagine my wife still again every once
in a while well she had like a bad dream
and she's like i had a bad dream you
were using i'm like you don't there's no
way i would use right now and again i
know it's always possible you shouldn't
say never ever
but i can't imagine it especially with
my kid and like you know and luckily
like even with i let her control all the
money and stuff like if i go where all
the stuff the checks go to her if i if i
go like i don't even want to know like
she'll like you wanna know how much you
made this week i'm like i don't care i'm
like i just wanna like i really don't
like um i just want her to hold it all
and i don't wanna
even know because it's just like she's
that she's
handles everything better anyway so
um that's good man and uh
i feel like i feel like we're
like we're
we've we've cut we've covered on the the
the addiction yes yeah we've got we're
okay cool um but dude tell me about the
twitch streaming dude
i love sorry i cut you off because i'm
so excited yeah all good man um no
twitch honestly i started so what was
cause is about two and a half years ago
um facebook start maybe maybe it's three
years ago but a few years ago um so
again going back to the family it's like
um i used to play lots of games call of
duty and different games in my
uh garage man cave whatever
um and you know my wife would be like
hey man i need help i'm cooking and the
baby needs this and this so i could
never just hang out and play games
and so i stopped playing for a while and
i was like man i really miss that zoning
out playing video games but then
facebook was okay we're starting this
gaming company
um and and we'll pay you such and such
dollars if you do 40 hours a month and
my wife
knew about it and she's like that's
amazing like you're getting paid that
much to do 40 hours of just playing
video games i'm like we got to do it
so it was like a win-win it was like
making money getting to play video games
and i'm being productive i'm not just
hanging out and stuff wow and then that
lasted for a year and then
um everyone kept saying you should go on
twitch you should go on twitch and i
didn't really know any much about twitch
at that time but i'm like okay cool
whatever and then facebook's contract
was up um and they changed a lot of
stuff but anyway i was like all right
maybe i'll transition to twitch twitch i
love and i only mentioned the facebook
was great because that got you started
yeah cause i couldn't just go hey babe
i'm gonna try this twitch thing because
the difference is with twitch you gotta
start you gotta get a billion you gotta
be partner and then you gotta hope
people will watch and if they do watch
then they can subscribe and donate and
do bits and all that there's no steady
hey you're making this much for this
many hours or whatever it's like hey you
can stream five hours or a hundred hours
it you might make the same money
depending on how much someone donates
right right so anyway but luckily i've
had a consistent sort of it's gone up a
little bit but it's enough that i do it
every day
um every morning around 9 00 a.m i i get
my kid ready for school i drive her to
school come home and i stream from like
9 00 a.m to like 1 p.m
pacific time
and i love it man i play fortnite and
call of duty sometimes kevin comes over
and we do what's in the box like kevin
just did uh the masters of the universe
for netflix so he got like a bunch of
new uh messages what's masters of the
universe he-man
yeah so they did a new uh uh like
it's called he-man masters of the
universe he-man revelations
um it's on netflix in the end
it's cartoon it's so there's five
episodes came out and then another five
are coming out so there's ten episodes
total of season one
um and it's awesome i love it and i got
to play a character in it i'm only in
like two scenes uh one uh episode with
like five uh sorry one scene so there's
like five lines of dialogue but it was
awesome but i play stinkore
nice yeah so
um
but um
so he got a bunch of uh masters in
universe toys he-man
uh castle grayskull
uh
skeletor remember yeah um and then there
was shira and all that stuff so is that
the thundercats no so thunda
guys but shira was the the woman of uh
he-man yeah came out i forget her real
name
yeah there's a but there's a lot of deep
but yeah it was a cartoon from you know
about the 80s and now they just redid it
in 90s right but it is same realm of
he-man thunder cats
but yes it was also kevin wrote it and
uh directed it and stuff um so he gets a
bunch of toy symptoms so we opened up
all these toys and we did giveaways on
twitch so it's cool so i do stuff like
that man and i honestly that and
cameo
so i've been doing cameo kim and i did
something for father's day
um and i just i was i didn't want to do
it i didn't want to do it and then we
did it for father's day and then i just
left it on and all of a sudden i'm like
oh my gosh i got 20 people want cameos
another 20. and i gotta tell you man i'm
doing the pandemic like deep of the
pandemic cameo and and twitch was a big
help for me like keeping in touch with
everybody like that because i'm going to
comic cons usually like i do at least
five comic book conventions horror
conventions my amusing stories stand up
at the comedy shows so i get to see all
these people and interact and chill and
all and then with the pandemic all those
got postponed
so i'm sitting in the house doing
nothing
but luckily i had twitch and cameo and
stuff and that that was a big help um
getting to hang out and interact and and
see all the peeps and and uh yeah it was
a big it was a lot of fun and it's still
fun i love twitch and and with twitch
you know it's so funny like
the way i heard you tell the story about
about the facebook thing it's like man
um i got my wife and i got my kid and
really what i want to do is [ __ ] sit
on my ass and play video games for hours
and like that was a problem and then
facebook came along and said we'll pay
you and now you can sit on your ass and
play [ __ ] video games
and that never would have happened if it
was just twitch because with twitch you
got to start from nothing yeah with no
guarantee when you gotta build an
audience you gotta make it into
something and you wouldn't have had the
the built-in excuse or or like a hundred
percent yeah that's true
with twitch you have to play like ps5 or
xbox or can you play like nintendo or
you know
anything yeah yeah and some people some
people don't even play video games
they'll sit you can literally sit here
and and have twitch streaming right now
and just be talking i've thought about
that you really can because it's live
yeah and then you've got the comment
section it's cool cause you could be
like all right guys like uh you know
we're talking about he-man who any
he-man oh oh you know joe bob number two
wants to know yeah so it's cool because
everything's live and and uh yeah you
could do it while you're recording or
whatever you should probably do it it is
i mean try it out dude people would love
it all right let's try it out if
somebody from twitch gets a hold of us
and helps us set it out if you run into
an inevitable issue that like someone's
gonna say something that they need
edited out so at the very least we would
have to be like okay like
sign a release form you know before you
go on sure you've got or we could just
do one without a guest too you know
without a guess yeah yeah and then again
i think there there's different sections
so you don't want to be too
i think you there's all these things
that can ban you from twitch but again
it's all the stuff you don't want to
talk about anyway like
racial whatever
but i mean for the most part curse do
whatever so
i uh uh yeah i think you guys should try
it and i think dk knows enough um
even has a contact because i think he
has a contact live yeah so cool i'm
telling you should check it out dude and
then it'd be awesome because we could
like co-stream too like if you're
streaming in live stream we could get on
we could play games together or we could
even
go stream like this i could come back
and we could i don't know just check it
out yeah t-pain was wanting to get
yeah
and uh and it's a meaningful revenue
stream is what i keep hearing i mean see
some of the people on there i mean
because there's all these
other yeah there's different things i
mean it's it's i wonder
i know that some people must have like
there's a dude man who i swear every
time i go on again i've been doing it
two years and i'd say
i get like i don't know
150 to 300 people consistently
um and then sometimes someone will raid
me and i'll have a thousand people
watching if kenny's over i might get 5
000 people but but that's every once in
a while like consistently like 200 my 2
250 is my sweet spot but i'm saying
there's some people you watch man
there's a dude i don't know what
i don't know why honestly personally but
every time i look i guess he was a
youtuber and he brought his youtube
audience but he has anywhere from 75 000
to 200 000 every time he signs on and i
look i go oh that dude's on oh my god he
has a hundred thousand people watching
him right now
who's the guy
i don't know how to say his name exactly
but it's q c w something
um
i i can't it's it's not even no it's not
even a word but i guess he's a youtuber
because i mentioned it on my stream but
the dude that one of the bigger dudes
that
that has a lot of numbers he's usually
about forty fifty thousand is tim the
tatman
which is he's a i get him though because
he's real like loud and he's got tats
all over and he's got his thing um but
anyway yes some of these guys get 20 000
people then so i mean again and as far
as you
um here and then i know ninja like that
dude ninja though yeah blue hair i know
he like went at one point and got like a
20 million dollar deal or something to
go to to the other
company but then they they shut down uh
you know talking about it for xbox yeah
i don't remember it could have been a
while back yeah it was a while back i'm
just saying but even for him but he
built his self on twitch so i'm saying
he was big enough on twitch to get
himself a deal somewhere else right for
20 30 40 million dollars i mean that's
so much it's it can be big yeah and it's
fun again i love it it's fun i think
it's you know what you could do it even
on your phone sometimes if i don't have
my laptop and my desktop at home because
you can like i said you can hook up your
like um
do a graphics card thing you can hook up
your xbox ps4
to a laptop or or uh your switch um and
different things but uh you can even use
your phone and do in real life you know
i already have sections for everything
just chatting irl like you know when
some people get on there and always
there i guess it was hot for a minute
hot tub streams where i guess girls were
literally just getting on and in the hot
tub like hey everyone welcome to my
twitch and it was like a big thing so
people would joke and jump on my stream
and be like bro i know what you need is
a hot tub stream you know i'm like wow
but anyway it it is honestly i i can't
i i i can't rave enough about it
honestly i dig it a bunch and they have
like a big twitch convention uh that's
coming up like next year in october and
and anyway it's fun you should check it
out um how much are you touring now
so right now so i i'm doing another next
week i go to rhode island for a comic
book convention and kevin's going to be
there and brian o'halloran from clerks
all the clerks guys
um so i did a horror convention i did a
uh comic convention in minnesota last
week in next week's rhode island so this
year i've done like this would be my
third one coming up um asked for my
amusing stories i did one in burbank
oxnard
san jose so again everything's just
starting back oh god okay just starting
back up the levity live in oxnard
yes i think that's my next one i think
that's actually coming up and like yeah
and i think i think i don't know about
burbank but but the oxnard and san jose
are linked up together oh yeah yeah
these just seem like if you're doing
that as part of that program um i think
uh like pittsburgh improv a lot of the
improvs yeah yeah man
i think i only have one more
show excuse me for
this year comic book and my amusing
stories but next year right now we're
starting to um
schedule everything and it looks like
kevin and i might do like a group
touring thing next year like a bunch of
stuff is starting to come up and um
my my amusing stories like all the
different
you know comedy venues and stuff where
because again everything got pushed i
had a bunch of stuff all year and then
all sudden they got cancelled and pushed
yeah
all that um yeah what it was such a
weird i'm sure for you guys too it's
like all sudden you're calling a venue
to venue and oh next week and next month
and next week and then i'll say wait
that guy canceled that got canceled when
it all got canceled all at once yeah
yeah i think that's what was close
it was a big blessing because like we
never would have stopped on our own we
would have been just touring ourselves
to death and then
thank god the pandemic forced us to stop
touring and just take a break that we
needed and and during that break we uh
we got pretty creative and and uh you
know started doing some new stuff which
has been
more uh like creatively satisfying more
like financially and successful like
we've just
we got a lot more podcasting and
podcasting starting yeah we've got a lot
more balance did you set all this up
during the pandemic did you already have
this band and then set it up dude we set
this up
like right before the panel like right
before what episode is this going to be
like so this would be like no like 81 or
two years ago so
wow but it was like we were
we shot like two episodes in person in
the can and then
but even during the bert one episode two
it was kind of covety conversation
right right the very first episode we
did with tony hawk he was like oh i went
to the oscars because someone in china
right parasite got shut down because of
corona virus yeah it was still just a
like an over there problem we weren't
even feeling it it was like fragile
timing was impeccable timing was [ __ ]
dope and yeah man like we just
we uh
we really like diversified we have
gotten some balance and and now we're
back to touring and we like we're able
to kind of really multitask all the time
and this is this is uh all this stuff is
strapped down so if you're like hey i
have a show that's two hours away you
guys can jump in this and drive down
your venue right yeah i mean
everything's pretty strapped down yeah
we love this steve lives to strap things
down
i gotta tell kevin if we go on a full on
tour again because we had again kevin
had bought a bus but it was so big and
it was comfortable as hell but you had
to have a driver but if it's if it's a
full-on tour you want the driver because
you don't want to be [ __ ] sitting
there having to drive you know
like i'll take this on like the
california run of shows like we've got
we're gonna have like a run of shows if
it's like in california even up to like
portland maybe then yeah but like if
you're full-on like we're getting ready
to do a tour bus run
and uh we're starting in in new orleans
and then like atlanta tennessee all the
way to colorado and you know arizona new
mexico and then we're going to do that
whole run in one shot with tour bus in
november
11th through yeah
[Music]
thing for the tour bus just to put it up
so that hell yeah um personal question
do you live alone in here no i have my
beyonce and i we live together okay and
she's in the van or in the house no in
the house i'm in the house i don't know
if he lived there because i live in the
band
no i'm just kidding
oh dude i would totally live with you
i'm assuming
this turns into a bed i knew it and this
is the second bed that lowers down from
the ceiling so it's like crazy double
like bunk bed deal i love it it's so
badass i'm down bro i'm gonna sleep in
here tonight
oh i see it's this part comes yeah yeah
yeah that that that lowers down i love
you got the fan i can't see without fans
so on my tour
my thing is stopping at target i get
somewhere go to the hotel then i go to
target i have to get a fan because i
can't see without a fan the noise of it
wow and i get a couple bath bombs and a
candle yeah and it's just sort of my
routine you see a lego so if i get bored
oh yeah dk says we need to ask about
your lego
addiction you and dk both have lego
addictions yeah yeah oh my gosh so i buy
like legos everywhere i go and then i
like start the building and sometimes
they bring them home sometimes i don't i
i was google searching where to park a
lot of money you know for for a safe
haven and it was they gave you a top ten
it was like cds savings account you know
uh lego sets and then it had costco
cards and i was like do lego sets retain
their value uh you know if they're in
the box and you don't open them some of
them but i don't i mean i guess a few
hundred bucks you could i guess you
could make some money but again they
would take up space so for example i
know that like my buddy bought
a set that was like 300 bucks
um it was like that you know whatever
the avengers helipad or whatever and now
it's worth like 600 bucks
but you can't open it right no no and
then there's a couple like old school
ones like there's this one my favorite
is called the creator series it's these
like three level
houses they have like the bookstore the
corner grocery store the corner gas
station and they're like 5 000 pieces
and they go for like 150 to 300 bucks
each time they come out but that like
three original four original which again
you won't get now but
and that was maybe i don't know how many
years ago but they're worth like three
grand
so again that but those are like three
that i know off top of my head that
would be from 300 to three grand but
what do you do on the road once you
finish building a set you take it home
with you sometimes i'll give them to
someone at one of the conventions or if
i'm at a comedy club whatever um i'll
give them someone um sometimes if i'm
half built i'll like put them in a bag
and throw them in my luggage and bring
them home and try to finish them off and
stuff but it's just sometimes like it'll
be like late at night and i'll just get
bored and i i don't know i could zone
out and build legos and enjoy them is
that a new thing or were you always a
lego guy i
knew where i guess i would say the last
couple years nice okay my my man cave i
have
is a lego i can make sure your man
keeping pretty epic yeah
yeah
it's it's packed with stuff to where
it's like
messy because it's too like i have like
a whole uh computer desk filled with the
city of these
because the other cool thing about those
ex
expert the
ones i was talking about is their house
is like a bookstore and then you have
the gas station but what's cool is they
have little holes at the bottom and you
snap them together and what's cool each
one has a back in the front so there's a
little back alley with like garbage cans
in that like you know a little basement
doors in the front we'll have like a
park bench with a street lamp or maybe a
tree but when you connect them together
all the
front sidewalk connects together yeah
see and there's corner ones so you could
connect them all the way in a big city
and so i have like 10 or 15 of them all
connected
on this one desk and over here i have a
table that has star wars and i have like
a platform with the death star which is
you know the big death stars
and then i have ewok village and the you
know millennium falcon and all this and
then over here it's like all the random
scooby-doo castle and
anyway
do you create youtube content like video
david channel and stuff like i have a
youtube channel um you know i just
recently started i had these guys
helping me edit together clips from my
twitch like it'll be like my intro and
then some clips of me playing games and
and again but it never it's it's
interesting i find that
with twitch and with youtube for me
personally
i don't know the recipe like i'll see
someone on twitch that like it's like oh
my god i love your stuff and like be
like follow my channel and he'll have
like 50 people watching them right eight
months later oh look he has two thousand
people watching him right i mean i say
that because when you describe your man
cave with the ewok village and the death
star i'd like i just feel like man i
want to watch a video about that on you
i want to see that on a youtube video
and like you're building legos even yeah
i've done a little that on my twitch
i've built legos and i've also a time
lapse of like a big lego project like
like when people would be sick i mean i
need to do some more different i need to
do different things like that on youtube
because mainly it's been like
again this sort of the similar stuff i
think my sensibility would be to let
them be different platforms and then if
you're gonna take clips from twitch and
then repurpose them
for youtube i almost feel like that like
uh
it it it feels like recycling
it feels like that kind of doesn't
belong in the one place i think that uh
you know we've got like a white board
downstairs and we write down ideas for
videos that we want to make and then
we're like okay what are we gonna do
next and and uh you know like we get
excited about them yeah i gotta say this
message just for dk dk can you get jason
a brand deal for legos please yeah no no
asking him for that
i think lego you know he i like he had a
contact at one point and when we went to
comic-con we did get a couple it was so
awesome because
recently i've sent a bunch i'm trying to
clean up my man cave to make room
because again everything's piling up so
i've been collecting i've been going to
comic con since 97
and i definitely missed some years when
i was a little messed up whatever but
for for the most part i would say from
97 until like
two years ago i went almost every year
missed two years when but i've been
collecting a bunch of toys from them in
the last uh 2012 i had
some lego minifigures
and i like had i never opened them up
and i had some other things
i put them up i just sold a minifigure
in the package for a thousand bucks
another one for 600 bucks another so i
put them in the store going this is the
muse collection i had this big glass
case with all my toys the hasbro
exclusives and over the years of comic
cons and stuff and i'm like i don't want
to sell them odyssey but i need to make
room but i can't turn down if you guys
i'm going to up charge them like 200
bucks more than what they're worth and
people have been buying them so it's
pretty cool but
it's hard because i don't want to sell
them but but my point is is is is yeah
like i just keep getting stuff and and
sending them um
to the to the uh
to the stash and and i've been asking dk
about
so like we've got a contact that the
comic cons we did for a couple years to
where they gave me some minifigs and
stuff like that but we could never get
the connection we haven't yet anyway he
might work it out eventually but like
rather like here is one of the big sets
like they have the harry potter diagon
alley which i really want but it's 400
bucks so i haven't bought it yet because
you know after buying like a set here
and there like
you know two two times in one month my
wife's like you spent six hundred
dollars on legos this month and i'm like
i'm sorry i won't do it again
so like i've wanted to buy it but i
haven't cause you know it's it's nice
but i just i'm waiting i'm sorry
everybody get on
jason's
[ __ ] twitch and start donating a
little bit of for the like
i think people need to tweet at lego too
like how did they not have a clerk like
convenience store lego build
then you could be elected yeah can you
guys blast [ __ ] lego if you guys are
listening like with clerks three coming
out let's do this i don't want to hear
i don't want to hear
like i'm waiting to buy something that's
400 bucks when i'm sitting here
promoting it
you know for the love of god
ellie uh so
tell us uh
what do you have coming out like you
just did clerks three it's okay to say
that yes yeah yeah clerks three so we
did clerks three hopefully guys it'll be
out
in around july again nothing's set in
stone but they're saying maybe july of
next year
um i mean mainly my twitch.tv forward
slash j muse
my amusing stories
um and then again my my there's not
there's no movies or anything right now
set in stone it's me still like i send
in self tapes
um i've done like a you know cameo here
or there but nothing's coming out right
now are you still doing the cameo now um
the cameo cameo i do yeah like my cameo
oh you're talking about appearing in
movies so i do do cameo but my cameo in
movies yeah like i'm saying i'm still
like you know i still put in tapes and
stuff but but right now there's no
movies or tv shows that i've done that i
could say are coming out right right as
of now i mean i'm kind of trying but uh
like
i have an interesting question i think
with uh
the jane silent bob strike back j and
silent bob
reboot yeah that like wasn't the
the distribution for those films like
like uh not traditional it was like a
super independent thing where you guys
did that on your own and in order to
like really launch it and promote it you
brought it out on tour where like you
were physically there for like like
special screenings of the film
yeah we did that with reboot um only so
so for reboot
we did is uh you know we shot jan zombob
reboot we got the money and the way we
were paying back the financers was we
set up a tour uh and we did like well
kevin did more but i forget how many i
did like 42 cities
and like 60 screenings and kevin did
something like 60 cities or something
crazy like that but we we toured with it
and we show the movie we intro the movie
then we'd show the movie and then
afterwards kevin and i would do a q a
slash podcast but yeah we did that and
that's how we made most of the money to
pay back the finances but we didn't do
it with strikes back but we we did a
reboot okay and then with clerk clerks
three
um we it's not the same format but we
still might tour with it just because we
had such a good time like just like we
afterwards we do photo ops with like
people and and uh um a bunch of
different things it was a lot of fun
honestly so so that that means that you
guys you guys own it you're exploiting
it there's no like studio there's no
corporation you get the finances you pay
back the financers and then uh once it's
like widely released then then you guys
are participating in the profit i
i don't know about that i don't want to
say yes because i don't understand that
i know that the money that we made
touring with it went back to that not
clerks clerks
was financed by lionsgate
but we still might sort it that's what i
mean so i think clerks
i know it's by lionsgate financed it and
is distributing it but i think they've
been talking about possibly what to do
with it just putting it out on screens
but also maybe touring with it
i'm not sure again don't put me on that
because i would not want to say anything
and even with the reboot i know what we
did
but i don't know like how much of a
piece we own they own and how all that
works that is i think that it would be
worth it for you to find out just for
yourself yeah
well again i leave it all to the wife
the boss the smart one of the bunch all
right uh but yeah i mean it's great how
many different things you get the movies
you get the twitch you get the the
touring you know and like all this stuff
and i really think there's a play with
lego and you're active on social media
you got instagram
instagram uh instagram twitter uh of
course tick tock all jmews from
everything facebook j-a-y-m-e-w-e-s
all right dude
[ __ ] let's uh i think you gotta get
to pick up your kid i do i gotta go go
get my kid from school and i appreciate
being here honestly and i would love and
again really um if this works out and
it's not a pain for you to involve yeah
i would love it i'd love to be part of
that
i'll give you my cell number right now
well uh everyone knows his number is
dude yeah seriously oh yeah so i think
you're like joking that i'm giving the
phone no thank you and thank you thank
you brother right on yeah buddy
so there you have it folks and let me
tell you that i know i'm in that little
live chat right now still watching with
you live chatters and if you didn't know
that then come on dude we're setting
every episode to premiere on youtube and
when it does premiere it's got a live
chat and i'm in there because i want to
make sure that i am reviewing the
episodes so that i will become better at
podcasting
yeah man committed to the craft dude
and i'm enjoying it it's a wild wild
wild ride baby come on yeah